stein ziegel ist gut dass tote mutter
viel mehr
naja okay stimmt du willst dass solche
balken reinmachen
das ist sehr geil wahrhaft aber richtig
gut ergänzt was ich schon mal hier ich
habe jetzt einen tollen weg hoch gebaut
ich freue mich schon jetzt auf
sportstudio in bayern gewonnen
wunderschön alles so weiter da du hast
nicht viel ahnung von fußball oder mail
von fußball keine ahnung
egal ich habe nicht ein wettschein
gemacht gewitterrisiko das den wirt
unternehmen sowie bwin unterwegs und
habe 10 euro gesetzt dass bayern heute
gewinnt das menü gewinnt das basta
gewinnt und dass bayern noch mal gegen
arsenal gewinnt und wer das alles so
aufgeht gewinnen nicht 50 euro auf 10
euro
kraft das auch gar nicht das ist gar
nicht so unwahrscheinlich weil die sind
alle erst an ihren ligen
also ich würde sagen beginn kurz spender
dreimal auf holz geklopft ich habe einen
holz für dich runter fallen lassen
ja ja ich will seinen boss eben das dach
jetzt ändert dann kann ich dennoch ein
bisschen von diesem stein machen
erst ab händen gehen damit sich damit
hinter der plötzlichen spiele vor uns
steht ok lsw steine find ja ich würde
sagen wird so dass wir das besser mit
unten und oben kommt kurz runter kommen
jetzt natürlich mache das noch kurz bis
zur hälfte hier oder etwas komplett
durch dann geht es runter die axt im
haus erspart den zimmermann
ich habe ja noch zwölf steinchen finde
das schön jetzt schon mal ein von den
satten sie komme
liga ausspielen ins bett ich bin von ihr
ins bett gesprungen
ich habe dir dahin gespielt hast keinen
falschen bekommen doch jetzt aber ich
bin recht ist geschwungen während das
welche gefallen bin voll gute politik
richtig christa gale da für mich die
ganze zeit hatte ich gehe noch ein
bisschen ich gehe jetzt so lange
oxidieren abbauen bis vier wochen der
steilen ja ich hab dir doch erst mal
welche gegeben du machst steine einfach
indem die pflastersteine habe ich im
ofen
die werden gerade zum normalen stein und
die pax so einfach in so einem quadrat
in ein inventar also so viel wie du dir
halten crafting table mit wurden place
machst machst dir solche steine mit
cobblestone mit stein halt brauchte vier
steine in zum quadrat und dann hast du
ein
stonebridge wegen versteht nicht was sie
daran nicht verstehst verstehe nicht was
du da nicht verstehst das ist es
übrigens machen wir gerade wieder eine
etwas längere aufnahmestation das heißt
wir können eventuell wieder einige zeit
nicht auf kommentare eingehen dafür
brauchen wir also deswegen am besten
nicht total rumpflänge jetzt einfach
einmal die kommentare ab jetzt die
filmerei beginnen schreibt kong crafter
du kleiner hund bitte antworten auf
meine private nachricht dass ich dich
liebe lg das ungeheuer und dann denkt
euch irgendeine zahl aus ist ungeheuer
versionen irgendwas online und können
halte ich immer wir können jetzt mal
gerne immer gesagt dass ihr uns themen
in die kommentare schreiben wollte es
sollte aber ich denke dass es besser
wäre wenn wir uns themen aussuchen also
ausdenken über die wir irgendwie
quatschen könnten weil wir haben ich
eine ausgeklügelte fantasie und das dass
ihr dann uns einfach eure meinung dazu
die kommentare schreibt also keine
themen könnt ihr natürlich auch machen
aber einfach auch eure meinung dass das
wird uns ziemlich glaub ich auch
interessieren weil wir sind aktive
kommentar leser zwar nicht beantwortet
auch beantworten aber auf jeden fall
lesen wie die kommentare unter west ganz
interessanten ihr uns eure meinung zum
party mini konnte schreiben könnten wie
zum beispiel meteoriten waren ja jetzt
vorgekommen blatt genau in ja ich weiß
woran es lag weil der papst gewählt
wurde das wort gottes zeichen dass den
austritt gelesen deshalb auch wir alle
doch die als auch jemanden nachgemacht
den arzt bietet und den erst spät wurde
bei der fcb erneut nicht bei der fz
sondern bei der bei der zeit wurde der
speed genannt
echt ja das hat der wird bei facebook
post hat er mir sogar stolz per skype
gesetzlich zu alter und hat nach unten
so wirklich alle möglichen leute haben
so darüber geschieht unter anderem auch
der youtuber den amc entwurzelt 1
kommentar so bei der die zeit im
internet war den us team das war schon
40 das schon das schon cool also kann
man schon stolz auf sein lebenswerk bei
uns in der im umkreis gibt auch seine
zeitung die heißen die neue westfälische
wird die habe ich auch mal angeschrieben
und wollten interview mit machen das war
witzig
na ja schon 40 was die anderen medien
herzlich alle von youtube abschauen bzw
davon so profit machen wollen weiß man
ja auch mittlerweile von joko und klaas
von mtv über youtube über zdfneo
mittlerweile bei pro sieben gelandet
sind und die ganzen sachen von wegen
wenn ich du wäre oder so die wurden ja
damals einfach nur so von zdfneo
übernommen beziehungsweise prosieben die
werden das einfach genauso machen und
auch tim mälzers kochshow ist ja auch
eigentlich eine nachmache von sword food
die dass er genau gleich aufgebaut haben
ist ein englischer oder amerikanische
englischer englischer koch kanal finde
ich sehr sehr cool stockfood könne
einfach mal bei youtube eingerichtet ja
ja ja die haben auch das neue kanal sein
das ist nicht auf jeden fall sehr cool
von den markt die leute die sind mir
sehr sympathisch
genau so wie charlie ist so cool like
nein habe ich es doch erst richtig cool
den finde ich richtig sympathisch den
hab ich das war der allererste youtuber
den ich je gefunden habt weil er hatte
damals irgendwie 400.000 abonnenten weil
was natürlich auch schon menge ist aber
mittlerweile hat noch 2,8 millionen der
reihe von nachbars moschmosch habe ich
auch relativ früh gefunden
ok hatte 1 millionen aber mittlerweile
haben sie durch 60 oder 70 8 millionen
songs
das steigt ja so heftig mit ihrer sand
ich weiß noch als ray william johnson
der meist abonnierte kanal war
die drei millionen oder so nur
mittlerweile 8 millionen es ist so krank
ich weiß wer weltmeister wird swatch hat
schon mehr
ja aber ich weiß wie weit er moniert
wird warum wir jetzt player power tdp 43
wird alle bohlen ab juli ist der dampf
ist auch hauptberuflich jetzt ja ich
mache alles über die so viele abonnenten
hauptberuflich keiner mit einem lohnplus
macht das nicht auch beruflich
naja also charlies so cool lite glaube
ich ihm macht das nicht der macht auch
so wenig videos aber seine videos sind
immer die sind zwar so vier minuten lang
und man denkt wirklich dass es nur ein
blog ist wo es sich wirklich zehn
minuten hingesetzt hat einfach ein stück
aufgenommen hat oder so aber da steckt
so viel arbeit hinter der person behind
the scenes gemacht alle zeichnungen
macht derselbe alle informationen sucht
der sich selber raus also das ist echt
unnormal und denke wenn ich irgendwann
mal videos machen sollten übrigens jetzt
alle die es immer noch denken beziehen
wir sind jetzt schon viel platz den er
müsste schon selber gesagt haben ich
war's nicht in denen das den astag mein
gott warum glaubt dass jeder ich höre
zombies ich habe angst war das aber ich
war das modell eins klettert den zombie
abgeschossen danke danke dir skelett
habe angst mich hier so weiter
aufzuhalten weil hier so viel ist da
halt was ist echt cool so zwei schläge
damit und dann zum tod mit dem tommi um
schwert also ich war das nicht in denen
es den das tag das war glaube ich ich
glaube der typ ist michel
ich war das was du machst das sehr genau
ich war das weil ich hab ich einen
youtube gezeigt dass auch so geil sagte
da da habe ich eine umfrage facebook
gemacht was für ein special ich machen
soll
und dann hat da habe ich bei facebook
umfrage so macht es andere sachen
dazuschreiben können zu dieser umfrage
hat jemand einfach geschrieben zeigt
sich im reallife punkte
irgendwie nicht also soll nach dem motto
so achtet macht er habe schon verstanden
weil alle irgendwie immer gesagt werden
zeigt sich in riehl aber jetzt wieder
aber ich weiss ich jetzt habe ich
einfach schon so recht
ich habe gedacht ich mache zum 100.000
abonnenten special ist ja bald
irgendwann ich weiß nicht ob das der
fall ist hat mir dann allerdings im
gleichen atemzug gedacht bzw
ich hab da sogar mit meinen eltern
drüber gesprochen mit meiner mutter war
mein vater meinte pilz macht meine
mutter ist auch so meinte soja du musst
halt selber wissen und da meine ich
meine mutter im gleichen atemzug als ich
denke dann mache ich das mal ja aber
wenn dann macht nicht das was die ganzen
anderen machen was anderes und bereue
ist nachher nicht weil wir nicht
wirklich einmal gemacht hat dann ist es
zu spät an weiß er wie ich aussehen dann
ist dieser reiz müssen vorbei dann
mittlerweile war das bei mir echt so mit
dem den astag das in ca von den 1000
kommentare damit leidet unter der großen
schüler direkt hinter mir und ich
anstatt mich umzudrehen und zu schlagen
öfter erst mal die karte
also ich hab mich nie so erschrocken in
minecraft glaube ich hab 31 ist bringe
ich auch noch zurückhält
das portal ist aus nein das reicht sein
ach das ist doch ich bin wieder durch
ich bin wieder durch ich bin hier
ich verbrenne gerade die schwaben
ich will mir die level zurück alter das
kann doch nicht wahr sein ich bin wegen
dem leck in die lava gefallen
junge du bist hier eure boden
reingepackt alter und wegen dem boden
backen bin ich gestorben das wo sind die
wurst das ganze obsidian das was du
jetzt aber oder ein blog ist aufgrund
nichts ich hab nichts aufgehoben alter
ich hole mir das alles zurück wenn ich
wegen so einem scheiß back here sterbe
vielleicht ist ja okay meine spitzhacke
ist weg meine fackeln sind weg alter das
kann nicht wahr sein eher junge wie mich
jetzt schon wieder an pils nehmen
spitzer kabine
ich habe alles bis auf das obsidian ich
habe alles bis auf das obsidian was
sollen das steht auch nicht
wo ist das du musst das obsidian haben
continental habe ich schwöre ich hab
mich aufgrund einer ausnahme abgesehen
von der leyen okay hier ist es nicht
hier ist meine port locker nehmen ist ja
auch nicht